einen wunderschönen abend zu finden 8 8
der talkshow die schlagzeilen macht und
das nicht nur in der form hier sondern
immer wieder landen wir große viral hits
also warten sie ab was heute passiert
denn heute ist dabei unter anderem
philip amthor cdu-außenpolitiker auch
bekannt dafür bei instagram mal
durchzudrehen bei mir ebenfalls von der
bundespolizei gewerkschaft heiko teggatz
und natürlich an meiner seite nena cink
bestseller-autorin und bild kollegin und
bilder an der ehemalige
regierungssprecher und
kommunikationsprofis ich möchte sprechen
über ein thema was mich wütend gemacht
hat tatsächlich als ich heute gesehen
habe wo die preise wieder sind an der
zapfsäule ich glaube das kann niemand
mehr bezahlen
nicht nur das benzin sondern auch gas
ist droht ein kalter winter und für
viele menschen die sich dann heizen
nicht mehr leisten können und ich finde
unsere politik tut viel zu wenig gerade
um insbesondere betroffenen menschen zu
helfen etwas zu tun für diejenigen die
nicht genug geld haben die nicht genug
haben um noch auto zu fahren zu pendeln
um zu heizen am ende frankreich hat da
ganz anders gehandelt da gab es einen
inflationsausgleich in höhe von 100 euro
für diejenigen die weniger als 2000 euro
netto im monat verdienen ich finde das
brauchen wir auch in deutschland und wir
können nicht länger aus reden ertragen
von politikern die uns sagen na ja wir
verhandeln jetzt ja
koalitionsverhandlung und wartet mal bis
zum nächsten jahren ein wir brauchen
jetzt hilfe
ihr paul absolut deiner meinung das geht
so nicht mehr weiter viele menschen sind
in deutschland angewiesen aufs auto der
umstieg auf die öffis wiese schönes auf
die öffentlichen verkehrsmittel ist zwar
da aber in vielen gerade ländlichen
gebieten da kommt der bus da wo ich
wohne in bayern sind nicht einmal in der
stunde und da ist pech wende den
verpasst und viele leute pendelt 30 bis
40 kilometer eine strecke zur arbeit
brauchen das auto auch und da muss was
passieren da haben wir ja gerade ein
paar gesehen du hast gestern einen
interessanten tag dazu gab und da habe
ich schon gedacht mein lieber schwan
jürgen trittin mitglied der grünen
entsprechenden fans sind ja noch gut in
seiner erzielen das setzte ich weiß
natürlich dass der viel durchsetzen kann
aber er hat einen vorschlag gemacht bei
dir und gesagt na ja wir müssen sehen
dass wir denjenigen die besonders
belastet sind das geld dann eben zurück
geben über das bürgergeld oder wie auch
immer aber hat gesagt eben nicht eine
pauschale entlastung der menschen und
das ist der falsche weg aber wir haben
vor allem gerade jemanden gestern weil
die auch jemanden gesehen der
verantwortung trägt und so geht's ja
nicht dass die immer noch ab morgen im
gewissen brief geschrieben ist verloren
der regierung sagt ja das muss aber die
ampel anders machen nachdem die
spritpreise seit anfang des jahres immer
weiter nach oben gehen also auch
herrscher ist als verkehrsminister schon
seit langem in der pflicht hier für
einen ausgleich zu sorgen und entlastung
herbei zu führen einfach nur zu sagen
freunde da muss was passieren geht so
nicht philipp amthor warum tut ihre
partei einfach nix und schreibt dann
briefe oder die gemeinsame fraktion
briefe an den vizekanzler und ihre
kanzlerin hat sich da in brüssel sehr
zurückgehalten also warum helfen sie
nicht den autofahrern jetzt ist erstmal
ein objektives problem gerade für den
ländlichen raum so wie es für bayern
beschrieben es gilt in meinem wahlkreis
in mecklenburg vorpommern ganz genauso
und noch mal verschärft gerade in den
regionen wo geringe löhne verteilt sind
sehen wir auch dass der spritpreis enorm
hart zuschlägt deswegen braucht einen
sozialen ausgleich zur wahrheit gehört
aber auch die spielräume der jetzt
geschäftsführenden regierung sind
natürlich ein ganzes stück weit
beschränkt also wir werden morgen den
bundestag konstituieren erster sitzung
in der neuen wahlperiode gesetze bekommt
man da jetzt nicht mehr aufgegleist das
muss die ampel machen aber wenn man so
die ganzen grünen politiker hört habe
ich im moment den eindruck ja sagt
mancher na ja ist doch nicht schlimm
wenn der spritpreis jetzt so hoch steigt
anton hofreiter hat ja mal noch höhere
zahlen aufgerufen und man hat den
eindruck den ist das nur ganz recht um
den vermeintlichen bewegungs druck zu
erzeugen auf öffentlichen nahverkehr den
es gar nicht gibt in ländlichen regionen
aber warum haben sie nichts was getan in
den letzten vier jahren also wie man sie
waren jetzt so lange an der regierung
nicht sie alleine haben wir ihre
parteikollegen als sie hätten ja längst
zum beispiel pendlerpauschale was suchen
ja also die pendlerpauschale will ich
mal sagen darüber haben wir stark
gestritten jetzt in diesem wahlkampf wir
wollen die beibehalten da hätten sie
schon machen könne ja und das problem
ist völlig wir haben jetzt diesen
staaten spritpreis anstieg der ist jetzt
erstmal ein effekt der letzten wochen
und monate so aber es war klar dass das
kommt und viele volt mit ein
klimaschutzgesetz genau das bewirken und
ich finde dass es an vielen stellen auch
echt ungerecht und wir müssen hier aus
meiner sicht nicht uns über so eine
pauschal entlastung reden sondern eher
schauen wie man da auch die geringen
einkommen entlastet weil die trifft
jetzt besonders hart ich sehe also in
meinem wahlkreis leute die irgendwo dann
unter zehn euro mindestlohn bekommen zu
dir ist das der blanke horror ja wenn
man jetzt hier spritpreise in der höhe
hat herr amt das ist immer richtig und
die sind natürlich besonders belastet
den den muss besonders geholfen werden
denen soll aber besonders geholfen
werden und gerade die leute würden
dieses jahr eigentlich stehen die mitte
die ist doch noch mehr betroffen davon
weil die sind ja jenigen die irgendwie
versuchen dass sie alles hinzukriegen wo
zwei leute arbeiten auch und auch
arbeiten müssen damit der ein gewisser
wohlstand auch gehalten werden kann die
sind genauso angewiesen darauf und die
brauchen natürlich auch einen
entsprechenden
ausgleich ohne das geht es da nicht und
die werden wir immer vergessen und unter
heißt ist immer hilft den bedürftigen
den wird ja auch geholfen aber der mitte
die wird überhaupt komplett vergessen
konnte wobei der eine punkt widerspricht
man sich auf den händler pauschale
natürlich ihnen krieger oder auch eine
absenkung der mineral wobei vergessen
wir eines nicht mineralölsteuer ist da
vielleicht der treffendere punkt die
pendlerpauschale hat nämlich ein gewiss
wichtig die wollen wir auch sozusagen in
der konstruktion jetzt auch auf die
aktuelle situation anpassen war für uns
wichtig aber das betrifft natürlich an
vielen stellen nur diejenigen die
wirklich substanziell steuern zahlen wir
haben bei uns leute und da rede ich
jetzt nicht von
sozialleistungsempfängern sondern wurden
fielen die in mecklenburg vorpommern
arbeiten und sehr sehr wenig steuern
zahlen die von der kalten progression
besonders hart getroffen sind da hilft
die entlastung über die pendlerpauschale
weniger und dem geht es nicht nur darum
am jahresende von der steuer was zurück
zu bekommen sondern da muss man über
solche modelle finde ich nachdenken auch
tanja scheine da muss man drüber etwas
sagen die polizisten
was sagen die polizisten jetzt spricht
er erstmal der kontakt sehr sagt die
hohen mietpreise in der in den städten
treiben die menschen raus aufs land die
infrastruktur ist in der regel schlecht
auf dem land also auch da wo ich wohne
fährt wie gesagt vielleicht alle stunde
mein bus zum nächsten still fernbahnhof
so wenn ich mir dann aber auch die
pendelei nicht mehr leisten kann
irgendwann weil die weil die spritpreise
so immens hoch steigen dann lohnt es
sich schon fast nicht mehr zum arbeiten
zu pendeln sondern dann bleibt man
besser zu hause und nimmt sich die
leistungen die der staat ein bietet wenn
man mal hochrechnet was man im monat an
benzin spart also sie meinen dass das am
ende dazu führt dass mehr leute in
hartz4 gehen ja selbst erstellte sandte
perspektiven ja ich bin komplett gegen
sprit gutscheine weil ich finde dass es
auch wieder etwas konträr zu meinem
prinzip der freiheit aus einem grund es
ist ja eine absolute mehr dass etwas
umsonst ist also ich hasse das jedes mal
wenn der staat sich hinstellt und
geschenke verteilt das sind keine
geschenke das haben wir steuerzahler
bezahlt das heißt wenn dann die
steuerzahler ein tankgutschein kriegen
frage mich warum warum werden die steuer
nicht einfach gesenkt es ist doch so ein
bisschen so warum soll der staat der
fürsorge mensch seine dann sagt lieber
paul ich schenke dir die tankgutscheine
du musst sagen danke danke lieber
steinheim konzert modell würde ich
wahrscheinlich nicht bekommen weil ich
nicht weniger als 2000 natur verdienen
kann ich eventuell
aber ich sage trotzdem auch wer unter
2000 euro netto dann soll man da doch
auch die steuern runter ziehen also ich
halte einfach nichts von diesen
geschenken sondern lieber dass man
weniger steuern zahlt und der mensch
sich dann selbst überlegen darf wofür er
sein geld ausgibt ich bin total gegen
diese mehr von etwas ist umsonst und
übrigens auch menschen die weniger als
2000 euro netto verdienen zum beispiel
sagen wenn man verdient 29 brutto dann
hat man irgendwie 19 1900 netto die
zahlen ja auch steuern deswegen ist es
für mich eine absolute mehr ich beginne
mich aber bei den steuern steuern ist
dort das problem dass am ende das dann
diejenigen nutzen die wieder was auf den
preisdruck schlagen wollen dh wenn die
steuer gesenkt wird dann gibt es in
vielen fällen immer wieder das beispiel
okay dann können wir jetzt ja mehr
gewinn abschöpfen das heißt der
automatismus dass das sozusagen für den
verbraucher abfällt ist ja nicht
vorhanden und das thema steuern darf man
nicht vergessen das kommt bei den
meisten im portemonnaie gehalt zu spät
an bei denen für dieser ist wirklich
relevant ist also ich bin der
ordnungspolitisch komplett bei dir ich
finde auch so der staat irgendwie
steuerzahlergeld als geschenke verteilt
das nicht meine wunschvorstellung aber
das grundproblem ist halt ganz einfach
und das ist das was in der diskussion
halt oft flach fällt leute die dann am
ende des geldes noch ein bisschen monat
übrig haben und die sich dann konkret
fragen wie soll ich jetzt noch den
einkauf bezahlen und darin wenn nicht
von sozialleistungsempfängern sondern
von leuten die ganz normal 40 stunden in
der woche arbeiten und für die ist es
aus meiner sicht mehr ganz wichtig den
kann man nicht helfen nur mit dem thema
da kriegst du am jahresende bei der
steuererklärung was zurück das ist für
die wenig erfolgsversprechend jetzt
müssen wir da schauen wie man eine
pragmatische lösung findet aber deine
skepsis theilig grundsätzlich will muss
auch für die 3000 euro net ich finde wir
haben da eine gewisse arroganz gerade
2000 euro netto ist nicht so wenig also
es ist natürlich also zum beispiel wenn
man nach dem nach dem uni-abschluss
einsteigt steigen viele bei 2000 euro
netto 1 333 brutto oder weniger insulin
aber 3000 euro netto es gibt ja noch
menschen die noch viel weniger haben ja
ich halte die weiterhin und sah die
grenze auch ich finde jetzt brauche und
große so giger als enger weil das ist
dass das muss muss man immer sehen viel
weniger aktionen in 2008 40 stunden die
woche arbeiten und diese 2000 euro netto
nicht erreichen das ist natürlich ein
thema und über die muss man mehr reden
ja wir niemals über 40 milliarden euro
ja ein mit der benzinsteuer pro liter
mindestens 65 cent also der staat hätte
schon da eine entsprechende möglichkeit
und ich sage es noch mal gerne da ist
auch die jetzige regierung die kann sich
nicht einfach warum mache ich nichts
bilder wahlweise ich könnte doch jetzt
einfach sagen weil es einfacher ist sich
dahin zu setzen sollen die regierung
müsste aber ich wurde von ampel folgen
ist und die sind geschäftsführend im amt
diese entwicklung ist nicht erst seit
gestern sondern schon seit einigen
jahren geht da nichts mehr da kriegen
wir nie gebraucht da die ein
verkehrsminister was machen wir da sagte
ich meine ich halte auch weil die
bundeskanzlerin weiß dass man jetzt in
diesen sechs wochen keine gesetze mehr
durchs parlament bekommt er kriegen wir
jetzt den steuersatz im zweifel auch
nicht mehr geändert das gehört zur
wahrheit und da muss man sagen die
senkung der mineralölsteuer bären thema
die grünen wollen aber genau das
gegenteil die wollen dass die steuern
steigen damit die leute möglichst kein
auto fahren weil sie auto fand finden
und eine lenkung haben sich neben ich
muss aber ich muss man auch sagen ihrer
partei da nicht gehandelt zu haben in
den letzten monaten gefasst und